[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi est 5
avril un spectacle qui fascine depuis
trois siècles les grandes zones
recommence à versailles depuis le 1er
avril les fontaines du château ont
repris vie valérie loiseau et graveurs
sculpteurs son inspiration c'est l'arbre
elle expose ses créations à la
médiathèque saint-exupéry à voisins le
bretonneux et un ring deux équipes et
deux ordinateurs c'est le chaos des mots
et c'est un match de boxe où les
uppercuts sont des mots un match s'est
joué le week-end dernier à trappes
on débute avec un rendez vous annuel à
chaque printemps dans le parc du château
de versailles les fontaines sortent de
leur sommeil hivernal pour les grandes
eaux musicales un spectacle magnifique
pour les visiteurs du monde entier qui a
débuté le 1er avril dans les jardins de
louis xiv
un reportage à travers les yeux
émerveillés de nicolas kirillovitch
[Musique]
l'arrivée du printemps et des beaux
jours semblent comme réveiller les
fontaines du parc de versailles
après une pause de cinq mois l'eau
jaillit à nouveau dans un jardin
spectaculaire de 77 hectares imaginé il
ya 350 ans par le roi soleil et qui
éblouit toujours autant les yeux des
visiteurs et sur les quais où c'est
vraiment impressionnant et magnifique
tout le travail qui a été réalisé vaut
le coup les gens du monde entier peuvent
venir et apprécier le spectacle
c'est une vraie bénédiction les grandes
eaux musicales parfait endroit pour se
balader et profitez en musique du décor
boisé du château de versailles
au total 55 fontaine sont à découvrir
et parmi les nouveautés cette année le
bassin des enfants doré créé en 1709
elle aura encore plus de sens d'ici
quelques semaines quand son écrin de
verdure a littéralement lui faire un
panneau arrière un fond vert
on dirait autour d'elle elle va soudain
ressortir encore mieux il ya vraiment
cette pensée du début à la fin
c'est une des salles de plus du château
le château de versailles il ya de
l'intérieur il ya de l'extérieur traités
avec le même soin et peut-être à
l'époque avec le même budget tellement
les fontaines coûter cher la réussite de
ce concert d'eau et de verdure serait
impossible sans eux les fontainiers ils
sont treize arpenter les sols et les
sous sols du château depuis le xviiie
siècle la méthode reste la même avec une
clé alia vient en fait de poser ma clé
de manège dessus pour pouvoir tourner la
clé qui permet de voir la vanne et ainsi
faire jaillir l'eau dans la fontaine des
enfants doré c'est l'aboutissement déjà
du travail qu'on a eu en amont pour
préparer les comptes n pour justement le
spectacle des grandes villes
faire plaisir aux gens et voilà il
perpétue aussi un geste ancestral plus
de 70 représentations des grandes eaux
musicales sont prévues jusqu'au 29
octobre prochain
une invitation à la balade un tour en
forêt avec ses sculptures et ses
gravures valérie l'oiseau se construit
un univers onirique l'arbre et les
plantes sont ses muses elle expose
jusqu'à la fin du mois à la médiathèque
et saint-exupéry de
voisins-le-bretonneux regarder au
premier coup d'oeil on reconnaît l'arbre
ses cernes qui nous indique son âge
l'arbre c'est le sujet de prédilection
de valérie l'oiseau c'est à la fois un
personnage onirique et un végétal qui
qui a une variation assez
impressionnante fin ça fait maintenant
un peu plus de dix ans que je travaille
dessus et je n'ai pas terminé le sujet
autant en passant sur le détail de les
corses que par la branche que par les
feuillages que par toute la mythologie
que ça que ça ricane valérie l'oiseau
travaille depuis presque trente ans avec
un principal support le cuivre pour
révéler tout son potentiel
elle travaille à la pointe sèche et à
l'acide j'ai choisi le cuivre parce que
j'aime sa couleur
la relation canton lancre avec l'encré
noire le le rapport de thon rouge et
noir
mais bon et puis c'est comme ça que j'ai
utilisé cette matière première pour en
concevoir des sculptures il ya
travaillant sur le thème du végétal donc
du coup j'ai amené le bois le papier qui
se surajoutent le matériau du métal
le bois et le papier de soie cette fois
elle travaille est pliée dans deux
sculptures dont une manière d'accrocher
la lumière très particulière où on peut
être à la fois dans des opacités des
transparences donc du coup il ya quelque
chose de très
de très sensuelle et qui renvoie aussi à
la transparence du végétal parce que
c'est ça aussi qui me plaît beaucoup
c'est que quand le soleil traverse les
végétaux on a aussi cette opacité
transparent des arbres qui se
multiplient comme une forêt qui n'est
une invitation à une balade une autre
exposition se tient actuellement sur la
mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville de
guyancourt teresa dinan nef qui se donne
aucune limite
elle pas un sculpte et g et 42 oeuvres
sont à découvrir jusqu'au 6 mai on
connaît de narcisse le mythe celui de ce
jeune homme tombé amoureux de son reflet
avec le saut de l'ange la compagnie
donne des groupes explorent une version
moins connue celle d'un deuil impossible
la pièce se joue et la semaine dernière
à guyancourt les images sont signés
camille lambert
combien de tours déjà mathis 13 ans ne
veut pas plonger
muriel sa mère et maître nageuse elle
lui demande de récupérer un corps en
plastique matisse ou narcisse dans le
mythe a une soeur jumelle dont il tombe
éperdument amoureux et cette soeur
jumelle moeurs et à chaque fois qu'il se
regarde dans l'eau son reflet il voit
cette voie cette soeur cette soeur perdu
et donc là le l'instant t de 2,2 de
cette pièce là il doit aller chercher ce
morceau de plastique censé représenter
sa soeur dans le fond de l'eau
deux comédiens sur scène dans un lieu
atypique la moiteur la chaleur d'une
piscine comme une invitation à grandir à
quitter son cocon serré la piscine c'est
un lieu assez fascinant parce que de
haut niveau de l'acoustique dont on
n'entend pas pareil que quand on se
parle dans un des mêmes dans un décor
naturel ce que l'on a déjà travaillé
dans des décors naturels mais là c'est
vrai que c'est pas pareil on entend on
entend quelque chose d'un peu watts et
en même temps ça résonne il y avait ça
qu'il était intéressant il ya aussi
l'odeur tout le champ sensorielle qui
est convoqué pour pour
quand on y va déjà en tant que nageur du
coup c'était l'idée de se dire mais
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être être
spectateur de deux d'une histoire d'une
fable le deuil impossible remplace le
péché d'orgueil
le narcissisme le saut de l'ange est une
fable sur le courage
comment se régénérer se reconstruire pas
de piscine pour ces matches mais un ring
attrape ce week-end l'école de musique
et de danse accueillir un nouveau type
d'improvisation l'improvisation
littéraire deux équipes s'affrontent sur
des textes rédigés en direct sur
ordinateur à l'origine la société de
production à des deux productions est
incertain papy nicolas d'andré s'est
glissée dans la salle regarder alors le
vice
la scène est en ligne
les adversaires deux équipes de catcheur
et leurs armes
un texte écrit en direct c'est le
principe du chaos des mots c'est
particulier il faut arriver déjà à a
dépassé de simplement son blocage à
l'écrit et dans capacité à pouvoir
s'amuser du clavier et laisser libre
cours à son imaginaire par rapport à ce
qui est posée donc par exemple au
premier rand
on donne un équipes it c'est à dire la
première phrase d'un roman et il va
falloir continuer pendant cinq minutes
ce roman là parmi les joueurs des jeunes
issus de l'association escaladent qui
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
on se reconnaître dans le plaisir à
écrire et redonner plaisir à des gens
qui ont effectivement peut-être des
difficultés qui sont pas reconnus dans
leur écriture là d'un seul coup y ont
leur offre cette possibilité là de se
connecter avec bonheur et avec plaisir
elle des difficultés ajouté à chaque
round des pénalités en fonction des
fautes et pourquoi pas découvrir
rien de demain un mot de littérature
avec les ouvrages d'une yvelinoise
stefanik exbrayat signe son premier
roman avec personne n'a oublié on suit
l'histoire de colette une jeune femme
qui vient de perdre sa femme son fils de
8 ans alors que tout fait penser à un
accident colette accuse son mari un
homme violent
malgré sa douleur la jeune femme va
enquêter pour découvrir la vérité
un premier livre intéressant avec une
plongée dans la france des années 1960
où les droits des femmes se développent
et on écoute le tard
je voulais vraiment parler d'une femme
qui soit à la fois forte courageuse
triste ce que je voulais avant tout
c'est faire un portrait de femme pour
moi c'est pas un polar parce qu'il n'y a
pas là il n'y a pas la police est pas
vraiment un polar c'est peut-être un peu
fort le terme thriller mais je dirais
que c'est du suspense psychologique et
c'est vraiment dans cette veine là que
je cherche je voudrais m'inscrire
[Musique]
pour le coup de coeur de cette semaine
direction et l'encours et le ciné 7 à
lugos quand vous donne rendez vous
écouter alors le coup coeur du si 17
cette semaine va au festival play it
again qui vise à faire découvrir ou
redécouvrir en salle deux grands films
de l'histoire du cinéma
donc cette semaine trois films à
l'affiché la femme du dimanche qui est
un drame basé sur une histoire
scandaleuse avec une très belle
distribution mastroianni libye c'est
trintignant le deuxième film c'est
mauvais sens leos carax tout le monde
connaît un chef-d'oeuvre dire un film
culte en tout cas avec denis lavant et
juliette binoche et le troisième pour
les enfants pour la famille c'est un
film qui s'appelle la ferme des animaux
où l'on voit des animaux se rebellait
dans une ferme contre le fermier qui
s'appelle monsieur jones et n'oubliez
pas aussi à l'affiché du ciné scène avec
le second coup de coeur le très beau
fils de nicolas bedos avec doria tillier
et nicolas bedos qui s'appelle monsieur
et madame adelman que nous avons encore
à la fiche
un très beau film qu'il faut soutenir et
voir en salle
pour régis leurs parce que c'est bien
honneur aux dames on commence avec un
one woman show ariane brodier sur la
scène de la royale factory les 14 et 15
avril prochain avec metal l'humoriste
pardon ouvre sa boîte de pandore et son
univers mythologique déchanter déjanté
regardez cet extrait oui je sais comme
dirait mon père en parlant de ma mère
c'est moche mais c'est confortable moi
j'aime bien les pizzas footballeurs se
ressemblent à des galettes dorées des
champignons noirs dessus j'ai une copine
s'est tapé un footeux est lui allé chez
l'orteil la fine ces poussières ou le
soir qui la crise d'épilepsie lui qui
menait la lada qui ont fait la grande
idée dans la barquette doit-il niveau
national les live un concert pour la
bonne cause la maison de quartier ou du
renoir de guyancourt à quel orchestre de
juger la participation est libre et les
fonds seront reversés à l'association
des paralysés de france
la maison elsa triolet aragon propose un
parcours poétique à travers la commune
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines six étapes
et autant d'installations avec un fil
rouge la figure de l'oiseau le parcours
est à télécharger sur le site de la
maison est le dernier rendez vous est un
concours jusqu'au 13 avril de passe de
deux jours sont à gagner pour l'ombre
d'un cours le festival se déroule à
jouer en josas les 21 et 22 avril
prochain et direction la page de
facebook de tv fil 78 pour y participer
de cette ville culture est maintenant
terminée je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis et je vous dis à mercredi
prochain
[Musique]